[Music]
in how rude news submitted by
glass-half-full woman was stunned after
her boss asked her to shave her legs oh
I thought she was stung by a bee
Oh stunned that sounds reasonable what
yeah she works at the strip club you
know it's kind of fun some people like
that [ __ ] oh really oh there's a hair
salon on a stripper pole
yeah but how they don't get caught
waitress strippers have bosses yeah yeah
it's a job yeah it's called the Mafia oh
I thought as a strip master the strip
strip master controls the strippers
I get it dog you got dangly leg hair
some [ __ ] that's distracting well what
if you just work at [ __ ] Target and
like you wear [ __ ]
so you like well that's fine but if you
got them out and I got to see it and
you're a woolly mammoth I don't think so
it's offensive
no I'm offended let me hear the story
let me know you're saying that we like
whatever leagues listen you you guys are
here for my visual pleasure and so if
I'm looking at you and I'm not seeing
like your best
no thank you yep that's right they
should put a law on that you have a
should should make it legal it used to
be institutionalized but that's all
alright so this story is an ASA
am I the [ __ ] that's a so this one
it's titled am I the [ __ ] for not
shaving my legs for work so here we go
it says so I'm a 21 year old female I
feel like I should say these things
about myself because these are usually
what people ask or say when they found
out when they find out I rarely shaved
my legs I'm straight I'm very feminine
and I just don't like to waste my time
or money on shaving my legs also I'm not
a hairy person at all you can barely see
my leg hair arm hair or even my goddamn
eyebrows I'll be as well that's not
always true Harry is relative okay the
only time I shave is when I'm dating a
new guy in my life
and I've been with my current boyfriend
for three years now also he doesn't give
a rat's ass if I shaved my legs let's
ask him so I work for a promotion
company where I travel and work at
events and festivals but today I had to
go into the office to grab some
materials and my boss was it was there
in his office so I stopped to say hi
before I left out when I ducked in he
awkwardly asked me if we could talk
about something I said sure and came in
and he shut the door he was so red and
stuttering but finally he told me it's
pretty embarrassing we needed to speak
about hygiene I was in literal shock I
was so embarrassed and asked him what he
meant my boss then proceeded to tell me
that a few people complained I didn't
shave my legs and they said it went
against company policy that I wasn't
being hygienic I was even more shocked I
told him I didn't understand what to
what that had to do with me shaving my
legs and he was just absolutely quiet I
asked him if he shaved his legs and he
still said nothing I then stood up and
said well he's a man who's needed a
shave his legs you boy I then stood up
and said if we were gonna keep talking
about this I'd prefer HR to be there and
he just told me that we didn't need to
discuss it any further later today I
just got an email from HR saying that
they would like to set up a meeting for
next week to talk further about the
discussion that happened today I'm
freaking out and it's making me so
anxious
am I the [ __ ] for not shaving my legs
for my job and it says edit so people
give you my boss hate I understand but
I'm not mad at him and I and don't blame
him I'm not sure if I feel like someone
was in fact pressuring him to talk to me
but about this because he is he is
usually very chill and is a nice guy who
usually doesn't even force dress code
and stuff but also I really have no clue
what he what really brought this on
all of a sudden since I've worked there
for eight months with no incident
because for eight months people have
been just enduring the hairy ass legs
and they couldn't take it anymore - bye
I can't take this [ __ ] no more
I gotta [ __ ] tell HR about this my
hair does not grow in that much guys how
would people notice even because she's
work she's working at Hooters and she's
wearing short shorts oh wait but they
wear leggings so it's not
she just said she's an event planner the
catering company for Hooters one of the
monster toys or something you know what
I mean she'll like bring cans out to
bring to people today is a promotion a
promotional company those people are
your company when they're out when
you're out and about so if they see
hairy legs on ya and you're like she
made me vomit and I'm over here trying
to get horny yeah what's up yeah usually
the girls are who get those jobs are
like really hot like fitness models a
lot of fitness models will get those
jobs like sometimes they get pregnant
and they get fired after those kinds of
toxins it was kind of could you imagine
being at like I really like hit music
festival and the monster girl hand
[Laughter]
machines job security to you guys mm-hmm
yeah people in the comments they were
saying things like well you know OKC for
our life wow this is so sexist they
wouldn't tell guys to do the same thing
because they're picturing like very like
corporate office kind of setting they're
also not picturing very hairy legs for a
guy on a guy no no like it's like well
first of all like I want to see her legs
and how hairy they are because if it's
just peach fuzz I'm like yeah he's
tripping but if it's like my hair then
I'm like man maybe it's not a good idea
to do this for this promotion company
but if people notice it the new you it's
there it's probably there it probably
looks like mustache hair on the legs
mm-hmm so then people were saying well
you know if you do work in a corporate
office workplace they do have dress code
and guys you never see you guys wear
shorts so mail leg hair isn't even an
issue because it's not even seen if
you're following the dress code but
women well in a corporate setting then
women can't show their bare legs anyways
if they're gonna wear a skirt it's
usually like below the knee and you have
to wear nylons or stockings with it that
doesn't even matter if you ever fly
Southwest then the guys do wear short
sometimes today and you see the Lakers
and then sometimes that's kind of yucky
too or UPS guys
the best jobs though yeah they do all
the time they're always fat guys with
really nice calves guys get grooming
rules too like for some companies your
facial hair and stuff like that or your
ear wax has to be inside your here yeah
I don't know I feel like if it wasn't
part of her job description like let's
say all she's doing is passing out
flyers and then they call her out on
that I'm like that's pretty [ __ ] up
also if it's not like you know when you
get interviewed and you pass whatever
that [ __ ] that's called an they hire you
and you sign all that paperwork if it's
not in there to like well what if she
shaved before her interview and it
wasn't a real description of what her
legs are like she honeypotted them
mm-hmm so after she just let herself go
after the eight months and it's like man
I can't put up with that what happened
when I met you you weren't that furry I
don't know your father you know I'm just
I like to enjoy jokes Sam her father
used to know actually honestly no but I
honestly you know Nicky poncing no no
but if Nicky had like super hairy legs I
think that'd be weird
Freddie when you wait what that means
that you did it does bother well I've
never seen it so it's like I've never
seen her legs getting good knots or
anything but like most lady hair though
it's never as disgusting as man hair
like when girls get when they're like oh
my god I'm so furry and I'm like what
are you talking about yeah it doesn't
look like pubic hair on your front
cannot you know it's just it's kind of
cute it's just a little bit of her she
might be blond - yeah yeah I'm girl to
have really fair hair you can't even see
like my friend she like hardly ever
shaves her legs but you wouldn't be able
to tell unless you like are there the
sons behind them and then you can see
like the whole thing and I heard that
it's a trend like in Brazil or whatever
for ladies to bleach their hair and
instead of shaving every day or
something so I don't know oh yeah that's
an I don't really care I think like it
shouldn't be a big deal
it's like armpit hair yeah girls want to
keep the armpit hair they want to keep
the mustache pretty much it is pretty
nice but I feel like the like question
is like what kind of job are because if
she was a stripper and like I ran a
strip club good day if I do but it's
like I feel like if it were my club I
would be able to say have this my son
Bette have some control over like groom
and like have some specific standard
where it's like if she's always seeing
people and like part of her job as being
a hot chick mm-hmm
then that's true can you know like there
is a dress she's talking about this is
like what's now more appealing more
attractive if I'm doing it in a way
where it's a dress but so if you're a
Playboy bunny at the Playboy Mansion you
have to wear the bunny ears right yeah
you have to be a rabbit as a rabbit yeah
yeah if she comes in with iguana you're
like yo this is not the Iguana Mansion
this is the play the Playboy bunny has a
unibrow done that disrespects my brand
without getting in trouble with the law
right he's I say respectfully please
shave your unibrow but I say that with
all you're trying to cater to then
hustler could picket it then that fetish
play yeah the fetish place has their own
dress code I guess but like at least my
point that I'm taking from Meg just said
is like how do you tell someone like
that I guess they've masked it under
hygiene right like let's say I'm running
a strip club as well there's a lot of
strip clubs in this scenario they just
call it dress code and not mask it under
anything but if I go oh okay something
like part of the uniform is you have to
have your armpits shaved you have to
show like six inches of [ __ ] like
that's what they can grow a mustache
right but then the mustache for some
reason can't go pass like the upper lip
but it's all in the regulation down oh
yeah you can't go past year so the
unless you're undercover then you can
now do whatever you want but there's
like very specific rules down all the
way down and even deadly helluva
strictly I remember I was trying to get
a job there and they were strict about
what kind of colored nail polish you had
oh wow you've been like types of
earrings that you would like this they
can call her she is ass like hair color
- what if we're doing jakey news and
person's time next to you smells super
bad you're gonna have a problem doing
yeah videos and being productive and
getting [ __ ] that's difficult when
someone stinks on them and if they smell
so bad to the point where you vomit
because one time you smelled them that
is how it would be bad that's really bad
how do you address that
it is an awkward conversation to have
because it's like how do you even tell
someone that they stink and you care
about them you like them but like having
a whole meeting where you sit down with
them you say hey bro like you [ __ ]
stink I don't think that's what you
should do you should have but that's
what you want to say right it's like all
right this might I'm trying to be as
nice as possible because like we all
care about you do you bring that up dude
so how do you I mean how do you bring it
up how do you bring it up that you care
about this person they smell like [ __ ]
they've been people been complaining
about them for the last like year it's
an awkward conversation to have but the
other problem is they don't believe they
smell like [ __ ] I think you got to be a
buddy and go hey uh I think we should
take a shower together I am curious how
they shower I am so [ __ ] curious if
you don't know how to talk to your staff
then that means you have a really shitty
relationship with them yeah because
there should be something where I'm
comfortable enough to like I'm so
involved with my staff that I'm just
gonna be like hey can we just go get
some food or whatever and then and let's
talk about you spank over some [ __ ]
sandwiches yeah I mean how do you bring
it up brother
litter you had a staff you always had a
crusty jizz stay on the side of his
thigh yeah I will bring you to bring you
I would bring it up because I care about
them I'm Alan oil and you care about
your business ultimately so I care about
them as a person and I know that people
are talking [ __ ] behind his back and
I've used to care about the bottom line
that's all you care about yeah yeah yeah
if you really cared about his feelings
you wouldn't even do anything you'd let
him keep his just hangs passionate about
it that's true or if it's religious like
what if he's like this is my part I'm
gonna call all my staff and I'm like hey
you know what we got to stop this
[ __ ] [ __ ] talking that we're doing
he's very proud of that just a yeah all
right we got a perspective so it's a
morning ritual he comes in his hands and
he planted on his pants these are just
hypotheticals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]